à l'image du célèbre chat larry downing
street
tu lis ça mais pourrait bien avoir neuf
vies jamais un premier ministre
britannique n'aura subi autant de tests
en si peu de temps c'est la deuxième
fois qu'une femme première ministre en
grande-bretagne
tout comme margaret thatcher elle est à
la tête du parti conservateur
turris a mais ne fait certes pas
l'unanimité les caricaturistes s'en
donnent à coeur joie depuis deux ans
mais rien à faire elle est imperturbable
elle est devenue madame l'exit malgré
elles car elles avaient voté contre en
juin 2016 les britanniques votent en
faveur de la sortie du royaume uni de
l'union européenne forçant le premier
ministre david cameron a démissionné
theresa may est propulsé au pouvoir
elle hérite d'un gouvernement
majoritaire les conservateurs sont
divisés entre adversaires et supporter
du brésil dont l'ex maire de londres
boris johnson a honoré certes mais les
mauvaises langues lui reprochent de
n'avoir aucune légitimité car elle n'a
pas été élue première ministre
elle déclenche alors des élections pour
renforcer sa crédibilité ou du milieu
coup de grâce son parti devient
minoritaire
cette victoire ressemble à une défaite
pour gouverner elle doit s'allier avec
lady député unioniste d'irlande du nord
pour avoir une majorité une véritable
gifle pour la première ministre et
résiliente donc elle poursuit les
négociations
un an plus tard son propre parti la
désavouer réclame un vote de défiance
chez un autre obstacle à franchir pour
cette fille de pasteur gosse
elle obtient la confiance de son parti
après qu'une centaine de députés
conservateurs les défier à chaque fois
elle survit aux tempêtes politiques
[Musique]
elle a un rythme un peu décalé mais
malgré les critiques
elle maintient sa cadence plus déterminé
que jamais à négocier un accord sur la
sortie du royaume de l'union européenne
et
et le royaume uni n'a jamais été aussi
divisés theresa may a t'elle d'autres
tours dans son sac
mais combien de vies lui reste-t-il ici
azeb wolde giorgis radio canada montréal